Ready for this?
Oh, yes, sir.
NARRATOR: General
George Washington's
lion-headed cuttoe.
One of only two swords worn
by General George Washington
during the Revolutionary
War, the lion-headed cuttoe
was Washington's
trusted side arm
during early
American engagements.
He was proud that
the weapon was made
in America, having been
custom forged by a bladesmith
in Philadelphia.
Lethal in battle, the
sword was designed
for rapid cuts
and brutal thrusts
to take down an opponent.
In the famous painting,
"Washington Crossing
the Delaware",
artist Emanuel Leutze
places a more refined
weapon at the General's
left side, which he did not
acquire until several years
later.
In reality, the sword
carried by Washington
on that fateful crossing was
likely his lion-headed cuttoe.
All right, veterans,
welcome to the kill test.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do,
I will take your weapon
and deliver killing
blows to this pig carcass.
Tyler, you're up first.
Ready?
[laughter]
I'm ready.
All right, Tyler, your
handle construction just right.
Your edge is very sharp.
Overall, sir, this
saber will kill.
Perfect.
All right, Gene,
your turn, sir.
You ready?
Let's do this, Doug.
All right, Gene.
This is a heavy sword,
very forward heavy.
But when you have a forward
heavy blade that you're hitting
and it meets resistance,
a cylindrical, almost
circular handle makes
it twist in my hand.
So probably, there is a
reason why the chain came off.
But your blade is sharp.
It will kill.
All right, gentlemen.
December 25th, 1776,
George Washington
leads the Continental Army
across a frozen Delaware River
to attack the Hessians
at Trenton, New Jersey.
And he probably didn't chip
his way through the ice.
But that's not going to keep
us from our strength test,
the ice block chop.
Tyler, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Yeah, let's do it.
All right, so Tyler,
your chain fell off.
But there's no
damage on your edge.
Your handle's comfortable.
Other than the
chain, you nailed it.
Good job.
All right, Gene.
Do it.
Your blade's edge is still
there and still sharp.
The issue is the rest
of your chain fell off
and it's picked up a bent.
I have less issue with
that and more issue
with this polished handle.
It's just hard to hold on to.
It is strong and it does
have an edge, so good job.
[inaudible] .
All right, veterans,
our sharpest test today
is the Hessian charge.
This is all about what your
edge will do to these dummies.
Tyler, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yeah.
All right, Tyler, the
weight of your weapon
does prevent me from
going very fast.
But you have a very sharp
edge all the way through.
Your weapon, sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Gene,
it's your turn.
Are you ready?
Let's do this, Doug.
All right, Gene, to be able
to maintain a good grip on this,
more of the cuts
I create are more
impact as opposed
to a slash where
it cuts all the way through.
So we have some
cuts here that are
more nicks, deep nicks because
you have a very sharp edge.
And for this test, sir,
your weapon will cut.
Awesome.
It takes a lot of guts to
get out there and compete.
I'm glad I did it.
And to come this far
is pretty amazing.
I've definitely
got the competition
that I was expecting from Gene.
But I think it's
going to come down
to the wire between the both
of us at the end of this.
Tyler, Gene, first
of all, I want to thank
you both for your service.
You're both
champions in my mind.
You've already won
your branch divisions.
But there can only be one
Battle of the Branches champion
when you walk out of here
with a check for $50,000.
And that champion is Tyler.
Congratulations.
You are the Battle
of the Branches
Forged in Fire champion.
Gene, your blade
didn't make the cut.
Please surrender your blade.
There's a lot of
Marines out there.
And there's a lot of great
guys in the Marine Corps.
And so for me to stand
here and represent
them is pretty humbling.
Tyler, congratulations.
You overcame every obstacle
set in front of you.
You beat out all
the other smiths.
And now you're the
Battle of the Branches
Forged in Fire champion.
That's a title that comes with
a check for $50,000 and, most
importantly, bragging rights.
Good job, my brother.
Please present your
blade to the judges.
I'm super excited.
When this whole thing
started, I had no idea how
it was all going to turn out.
Feels good to have
represented the Army.
The fact that I just won
$50,000 is starting to set in.
I'm Sergeant Tyler Hackbarth
and I'm the new Battle
of the Branches champion.
George Washington's
colichemarde.
I've never even
heard of this thing.
Never seen it, nothing.
Right now, my heart
is just racing,
because I'm freaking out.
NARRATOR: The colichemarde was
a unique dueling sword that
became popular during
the late 17th century
and was a favorite blade
style of George Washington.
The weapon had an
extremely broad
forte, [inaudible] skate
blade ample parrying strength.
However, the sword rapidly
tapered to a big point,
allowing for precise thrusting
and stabbing attacks.
An avid sword collector,
George Washington
even had a colichemarde
blade small sword
at his side while swearing in
as America's first president.
The weapon was such an iconic
part of Washington's persona,
it can even be spotted
alongside the first president
in this iconic 1824
John Trumbull painting.
To find out what
kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do, I
will take your colichemarde
for harassing cuts and
thrust to this pig carcass.
Josh, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Not really, but go ahead.
All right, Josh, first up,
it's got a nice weight to it.
Now your handle construction,
it is small enough to where
I can get my hand around it.
But it doesn't roll.
Your edge, as you
can see, is sharp.
It will kill.
Thank you, sir.
All right, Dan.
It's your turn.
You ready for this?
Let's do it.
All right, Dan, you have
a very aggressive tip.
The thrusting worked very well.
But your edges right
here are not sharp.
I can even move it
around with my glove.
It's not cutting it.
You can see that your
blade took a bend.
But overall, because
you're able to thrust,
this blade, sir, will kill.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen, it's
time for the strength test,
our cherrywood chop in
honor of George Washington.
The colichemarde was known as
a fast, light, flexible weapon.
It was designed for the duel.
So to test the
strength of your blade,
I'll be doing several tip
cuts against that wood
and then thrusting
into it, flexing
your blade in both directions.
Make sure that tempers
right and that that blade
doesn't pick up a set.
Josh, you're up first.
You're ready?
Go for it.
All right, Josh.
There are a lot of
pointy bits on this guard
that don't need to be there.
That really digs
right into your hand.
Other than that, did well
and flexed very nicely
and came back to true.
So good job.
Thank you.
All right, Dan,
are you ready to go?
Sure, let's go.
I commend your effort
in making a blade
that's very nicely done.
But the heat treat on this
blade has just failed.
I no longer know where the tip
it, which is disappointing,
because I think you
did a beautiful job
constructing this weapon.
All right, bladesmiths, to
find out how sharp your weapons
are, I will take a colichemarde
and deliver harassing slashes
and thrust on these sandbags.
Josh, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Sure.
All right, Josh.
Once again, very sharp edge
on your blade right here.
Easily cuts through
these sandbags.
It stayed true.
Easy to align and see
my target and cut it.
And it will cut.
Thank you.
Dan, you're ready?
Yep.
Let's do this.
Dan, when I look at the
bend on this colichemarde,
I won't be able to
stab straight and true.
I won't really know
where the tip is.
And for me, that's
a real problem.
I don't feel like I can test
this blade in the same way
I can test the blade before it.
Because if I have to do
any kind of corrections,
that's not a fair test.
Unfortunately, Dan, your
blade did not make the cut.
And for that reason,
I have to ask
you to please leave the forge.
As a period piece, as a wall
hanger, my blade was spot on.
But as a sword, it just
didn't make the cut.
Josh, you are the new
Forged in Fire champion.
And that is a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job.
This is hands down one of
the best moments of my life.
Good job.
To my wife and my kids, this
just proves that you can do it.
It's just a matter
putting your mind to it
and putting your heart in.
Ulysses Grant's
Donaldson sword.
NARRATOR: The Donaldson sword
is a commemorative blade awarded
to General Ulysses S.
Grant for his victory
at Fort Donaldson
in February of 1862,
one of the first major union
victories of the Civil War.
The weapon features
a highly ornate
handle an engraved blade based
on the popular 1862 officer
sword.
After General Grant's death,
his wife donated the sword
to the Smithsonian
Institute in 1886
and it remains under
their care to this day.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
The sword was made to be
a dueling type of weapon.
So I'm going to try to
deliver the same light slashes
and thrust on this
ballistics dummy.
Paul, you ready for this?
Oh, yes, sir.
All right, let's do this.
All right, Paul. let's talk
about your version of General
Grant's Donaldson sword.
The weight on this blade is
not that of a dueling sword,
because it requires a little bit
more than just wrist movement.
But it is a great cutting sword.
Your edges are sharp.
Even with the harassing
cut, you can see,
they're cutting deeply.
And more importantly,
sir, it will kill.
Isaac, your turn, sir.
You ready for this?
I guess.
OK.
All right, Isaac, let's
talk about your weapon here.
What I like about
it is the time you
took to put these
details that we
were asking for on your sword.
Every cut was deep and
not a lot of powers
required when you're
swinging something so light.
But probably hitting
the bone, your blade
did take a slight bend.
But overall, sir,
your weapon will kill.
Thank you.
Paul, Isaac, you
know what time it is,
time for the strength
test, a fan favorite
and the cringeworthy flex test.
And we're going to
flex those blades to 35
degrees in either direction.
If you're still holding
true, we're going to go to 45
degrees in either direction.
Paul, you ready for this?
Not really, but go
ahead and bend away.
So Paul, as far as the
construction of your blade
goes, the handle's comfortable.
We saw how well this sword cuts.
You did a good job.
But if you look
into that blade, you
can actually see a dark spot
on both sides of this blade.
And whether that's a
flaw that you picked up
in the forging process
or a flaw in the steel,
I have no way of really
telling right now.
But the grain structure
on this looks fine.
But having it shatter,
having it pop like that,
that's a big issue.
Well, Paul, we absolutely
hate to see that.
You put a lot of
work into your blade.
You made it past the
35 on both sides,
but you did break
on the way to 45.
But you're not out
of the fight yet.
Isaac, you've got to survive
both of the 35 degree turns
as well as the official ruling
of 40 degrees toward the south.
[sigh]
Congratulations, man.
Thanks.
Paul, I want to say thank
you for your hard work.
You have what it takes
to fight in this forge.
But unfortunately, I'm going
to have to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
Thank you, gentlemen.
This was such a good experience
and it was an honor to compete
against such a good competitor.
Isaac, we asked
you to build General
Grant's Donaldson sword.
You performed phenomenally and
built us something that is not
only functional, but absolutely
beautiful and stunning
to look at.
You are the Forged
in Fire champion
and you just earned yourself
a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
I'm the Forged in
Fire champion, baby.
Woo!
How do you feel?
Cloud nine.
I'm feeling so good.
That's a remarkable
piece of work
and you should be
incredibly proud of it.
Thank you.
There's just too
many feelings going
through my head and my
heart to really process
what's all happening right now.
I can't believe it.
I'm feeling so good.
The M1832 foot
artillery sword.
NARRATOR: The M1832
foot artillery sword
is the American recreation
of a French artillery
sword modeled after the
infamous Roman gladius.
Featuring a short
and stout blade,
the weapon has an ornate
handle cast entirely of brass.
Feathers or scales
are traditionally
molded into the handle and an
eagle is etched into the palm
well to honor America.
Produced at the end
of the 19th century,
the M1832 was issued
to artilleryman,
but more widely used to clear
paths through thick brush
and as the last
minute life saver.
When called upon, the sword
was lethal in close quarters
and was employed by
disemboweling horses
to bring down the
rider, who then
was finished in quick fashion.
To find out what
kind of deadly force
your artillery
swords can supply,
I will take your weapon,
deliver killing slashes
on this ballistics dummy.
John, you're up first.
You're ready for this?
Ready.
All right, John, first
up, I like the beauty
of an all metal construction.
And the Damascus fashion
you have here is gorgeous.
The weight is all the
way in the handle allows
for a good recovery and
forward delivery of strikes.
Your edges are very sharp.
Every cut cuts deep, cuts to
the bone, and into the organs.
And most importantly,
sir, it will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Tom, your turn.
You ready?
Get her done.
All right, Tommy, let's
talk about your weapon here.
It is a beast.
The weight of your
weapon is all forward
that it actually
takes a lot to pull
it away for a second strike.
But the thing that your beaste
does have is a very sharp edge.
Every cut is very deep.
But it takes a lot of work
to control this beast.
More importantly though,
sir, it will kill.
All right, gentlemen, it's
time for the strength test.
Now why bring swords
to a gun range?
Well, so you two can join one
of our two clubs, the oh my god,
they broke my blade
with a bullet club,
or the bulletproof sword club.
So to test your
blades, we've got
our firearm locked in a vise.
We've got your blade locked
in another vise down range.
We're going to fire one
round at that thing.
It should split that bullet
clean or, worst of all,
see that blade shatter.
John, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yeah.
OK, Fire.
Four holes.
I thought I felt that
you lost a hair of edge.
That's bullet hung
up on the blade.
Awesome.
You're going to
actually see top
and bottom where that bullet
went across your blade.
You can see there's four
holes in thing over there.
That's the lead
core and the jacket
going in different directions.
So you split that bullet nicely.
I don't see any
damage to your blade.
Well done.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, Tommy,
are you ready for this?
NARRATOR: Let's do it.
Fire.
Here we go.
All right, Tommy, well,
your blade took some damage
in that bullet test.
There's a chip in one spot.
And the other spot, you can
actually hear my fingernail
catching on that roll.
Having said that, it
doesn't feel bad in my hand.
But it is very heavy
for this type of sword.
But as far as the strength test
goes, as you can clearly see,
it took some damage.
All right,
bladesmiths, now that we
know your blades
can take a bullet,
it's time to find
out if they can cut.
This is the sharpness
test, the shot bag slice.
Now unlike the
strength test, this
is all about what the
edge of your blade
will do to these shot bags.
A sharp blade
should cut cleanly.
John, you're up first.
You ready for this?
- Yeah.
- Let's do this.
Good job, man.
This is what I love about
your blade, the balance.
It is fun to wield.
It is fun to move around.
It cuts with every slice.
It will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Tommy,
it's your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
- Let's do it.
Awesome.
All right, Tommy, on
the stationary cuts,
it cuts cleanly.
It's a sharp blade.
Now when I'm moving around
and changing my balance,
because of the weight of the
blade it does affect the way
I'm cutting.
So some of the cuts are not
clean all the way through.
There are some strands.
More importantly,
your weapon here,
though, a beast, it will cut.
John, Tommy, the judges have
made their final decision.
Our new Forged in
Fire champion is John.
Congratulations.
You're the Forged
in Fire champion.
Tommy, unfortunately, your
blade didn't make the cut.
Tommy, this came
down to three things.
The weight of your blade
made it harder to wield.
Its rough construction
and the fact that it took
damage in the strength test.
Those are the reason
we're letting you go.
Tommy, you made a beast.
But today, it
didn't make the cut.
Please leave the range.
- Thank you, sir.
- Thank you.
From here, it's
just about getting
better and refining my skills.
John, congratulations.
You are the Forged
in Fire champion.
And that is a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
Thank you.
It feels great to be the
next Forged in Fire champion.
I'm super proud of all
the work that I've done.
I've come here and
done tasks that I never
would have expected from
myself and the challenges
that I never would
have tried before.
And I've succeeded.
So I feel awesome.
The Springfield 905 bayonet.
We will be providing
a Springfield
1903 replica rifle to you.
Your bayonets must fit snugly
and securely on your rifle.
[bleep]
NARRATOR: Developed
in the early 1900s,
the m1905 Springfield
bayonet was
used by American infantry
for nearly 70 years
from World War I
through the Vietnam War.
These versatile
weapons were designed
with a mechanical device in the
pommel that attached securely
to the rifle while also
featuring a comfortable handle,
making it a very effective
weapon in hand-to-hand combat.
Featuring a sharp single edge,
a long fuller, and a false edge,
this lightweight bayonet
could quickly deliver stabs
and slashes to an opponent.
The bayonet is still used today
during military ceremonies
and can be seen in several
classic war films like 1998's
"The Thin Red Line".
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
The first mission today
is to take your bayonet
and affix it to
Springfield rifle
and deliver some killing blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Then I will dismantle
the blade from the rifle.
And let's see what
kind of lethal damage
it will do on its own.
Josh, you're up first.
You ready?
As ready as I can be.
That's pretty badass.
All right, Josh, let's
talk about your bayonet here.
When I affixed this
on to the rifle,
it had a very nice
match with the railing
in there and your pin.
It was very secure.
Now your edge is very sharp.
It's definitely lacerates
deep into the bone.
On its own, the
handle construction
matches nicely on my hand.
Overall, sir, it will kill.
Awesome, thank you.
All right, Brad, your turn.
So are you ready for this?
Let's go for it.
All right, Brad, first
up, the handle construction.
It is a little bit
on the smaller side.
But there are no sharp edges.
And the flair you
have here actually
gives me good
attention and I can
get all the way to the guard.
At first, I was a little bit
worried about your cutter
pin right here.
It looked flimsy, but
the minute I put it on,
it wasn't an issue at all.
It stayed affixed to the
bayonet quite tightly.
Your weapon is straight.
Every cut was very deep
into this ballistics dummy.
Overall sir, your
weapon will kill.
Thank you, sir.
Bladesmiths, welcome to
the strength test, the steel
can, stab, and barricade chop.
This test is all about what
happens to your bayonets
and not what happens
to the targets.
Josh, you're up first.
You ready?
No.
[bleep] Here's my finish.
All right, Josh, well,
it survived really well.
There is sections
on here that are
now not as sharp as they were.
But nothing rolled over.
Nothing chipped out.
Your point is still
nice and sharp.
It performed really well
on the strength test.
Nice job.
- Awesome.
Thank you.
All right, Brad, are
you ready for this?
Well, my nan said,
don't break it.
But go for it.
Well, Brad, what you
got here, your blade edge
took some damage.
The blade's taken a bit of
a bend to one side here.
It's cheating to the right.
But your point didn't
take any damage.
It's all in one piece.
It's a nice, sturdy blade.
Nice job.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths,
this is the sharpness
test, the military bag slice.
To find out how sharp your edges
and point of your bayonets are,
I'm going to take a stab
at these military bags.
Josh, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's go for it.
All right, Josh,
you're bayonet right here
had no problems puncturing the
bag and slicing it to pieces.
It'll cut.
Sweet.
Thanks.
All right, Brad,
your turn, sir.
Shall we do it?
Of course, have at you.
All right, Brad, let's
talk about your blade
here, wicked sharp.
It punctured easily
in the military bag.
At the same time, the edges
cut like hot steel on butter.
Overall, sir, for this
test, it will cut.
Thank you, sir.
While you both brought us
amazing work, only one of you
go home with the title.
And the Forged in
Fire champion is Josh.
Holy shit.
Congratulations.
Brad, unfortunately, you're
not going home with the win
today and Doug's
going to tell you why.
I commend you on your work.
Your knife performed
very well on our test.
But it was also the
only knife that took
a band on the strength test.
And for that reason, your
blade did not make the cut.
Brad, unfortunately,
that means
we have to ask you to please
leave the forge floor.
I understand.
Have a good one, guys.
Pleasure, man.
Thank you.
Well, Josh, that means you
are the Forged in Fire champion
and you're going home
with a check for $10,000.
How does it feel?
I feel awesome.
Congratulations.
I don't even know, man.
I'm still trying to
sink in that I won.
A little overwhelming.
I can't wait to tell my wife.
She had a lot of confidence
in me from the very start.
I'm excited to let her know
that, hey, you were right.
I won.